[تصفيق]
هكذا هي الاجواء ليلا داخل ازقه المدينه
القديمه بطرابلس التي تقام على ارضها
فعاليات ليالي المدينه بعد صيانه هزائم
منها وتحويلها من مكان مهمل لسنوات طويله
الى مقصد للعائلات والشباب في ليالي رمضان
مثل هذه النشاطات لا شك بان ترس الرساله
بان ليبيا على طريق الاستقرار ان قطعنا
شوط طويل في هذا المسار نحو الاستقرار
اكثر من 600 منشط ثقافي وفني تسعى اللجنه
المنظمه لتقديمه لزوار المدينه تنوعت بين
عروض راجله تحاكي فيها تاريخ الجهاد
الليبي ومسرح للطفل وندوات ثقافيه
بالاضافه الى الحكوات التي يقص القصص
للاطفال وفقرات للتعريف بالشخصيات
التاريخيه الليبيه
حقيقه هو الهدف منها التحريك لعجله الفن
والثقافه والابداع بالاضافه الى لدينا حتى
حركه اقتصادي تحريك الاقتصاديه اقبال كبير
على زياره المدينه والمشاركه في الانشطه
الترفيهيه من مختلف الاعمار التي تستمر
حتى ساعات الصباح الاولى وسط تامين مشدد
من رجال الامن ما عندناش تاريخ الا المدين
القديمه نرجعوله تاريخ مشرف تاريخ فيه
بطولات الناس كلها تطلع من بيوتها تطلع
زهريات في حياه ليله في ليبيا على الاقل
في طرابلس بصراحه المدينه قديمه بدت معلم
مزار ومش عادي
العواصم العربيه اللي تحتفي بشهر رمضان
وخاصه مع الجو الربيعي الان يعود عمر بعض
المباني هنا الى اكثر من 500 عام عانت
الاهمال لسنوات طويله حتى بدا بعض اجزائها
بالسقوط قبل التدخل الحكومي الاخير
لصيانتها وتحويلها الى مزار سياحي ليالي
المدينه القديمه في طرابلسا مختلفه هذا
العام حيث اصبحت المدينه مقصدا للزوار
الراغبين في الترويح عن انفسهم متجاهلين
الصراعات السياسيه التي حرمتهم من مثل هذه
الاجواء لسنوات طويله منير الاشهب طرابلس
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات